- Mm-hmm. All right.
Hey, palsies!
My name is Cody,
and I'm a Helpster.
That means a monster who helps.
And because I love, love, love
to help so much,
I'm making these videos called...
I love spending time with my friends
Mr. Primm and Scatter and Heart.
But even when we're apart,
we still find ways to be together.
Like...
We send each other cards...
and handmade little presents.
Heart sent me this painting.
Hey, I'm wearing
the same outfit. Huh.
You can send your friends
and family cards and drawings, too.
Or you can talk on the phone,
or video chat,
or even read books to each other.
Or you can do what my friends
and I do when--
Oh. W-w-w-w-wait.
I'll show you.
(phone ringing)
- Mr. Primm speaking.
- Mr. Primm, it's Cody.
- My dear Cody!
Wonderful to hear from you.
- Aw, you too.
- Oh, wait. Let me get Heart
and Scatter on the phone, too.
- (gasps) Great.
- Hello!
- (gasps)
- Heart's residence.
Heart speaking.
- Oh. Heart and Scatter,
it's Cody.
- Hooray!
- Hello, Cody, my friend!
- Hi, palsie!
Hi, buddy bud!
- And Mr. Primm remains
on the phone as well.
- Oh, great. Hey, is everybody
ready to make a new song?
- I can't wait.
- Oh, yes, yes.
- Yes. Yes, indeed. Absolutely.
- Okay, great.
Now you all make the music,
and I'll sing the words.
- Ooh. I will start.
(beatboxes)
(Scatter and Mr. Primm vocalizing)
- ♪ It sure feels like we're together ♪
♪ 'Cause it's all about reaching out,
no matter how far ♪
♪ It sure feels like we're together ♪
♪ And that's because we are ♪
♪ That's because we are,
that's because we are ♪
- Oh, that was so great!
- Hooray!
- Huzzah!
- You sound wonderful! Ha-ha!
Hey, thanks for watching.
I'll be back soon.
And until then, see what you can
do to help the people
and the monsters around you,
because everyone
loves a helping hand.
- Say goodbye, everybody!
- Great. Bye, everybody!
- Bye, everybody!
- Bye! Fare thee well.
- Goodbye!